bien alors patrick dupont on va faire
une interview dernier clou dans les
guignols
dès que ma fille est plus là voilà je
constate que personne bouge merci ça me
fait très plaisir et je tiens beaucoup à
ça alors dernier coup c'est facile
dernier coup dur danny groulx dit en
accident de quad l'accident dernier coup
de coeur coups de coeur adriana karembeu
je comprends le dernier dernier passe il
ya cinq minutes on pompe où j'avais mis
à dans les coups de poing dernier coup
de poing le procès ouais lundi coup de
folie d'un et coup de folie
un très joli cadeau pour maman dans les
coups de foudre
dernier coup de foudre obama petit
partenaire maintenant landowski mari
femme dans les coups de gueule dernier
coup de gueule je veux qu'on m'écoute
répétition ah oui je veux travailler
alors il veut répéter je trouve qu on
passe trop de temps sur les autres
passez sur moi dernier coup de bluff
dernier coup de bluff
quand est-ce que je bluffe tout le temps
sauf lave sauf ce soir vous pouvez pas
ici un dernier coup de barre dernier
coup de barre c'était ce matin à 10h30
j'étais accroché à la barre harry
dernier opus normal bienvenue coup de
blues
dernier coup de blues olala yaba ya deux
jours je rentre à la maison crevé il
était minuit et demi je mets la radio
évidemment c'est barbara qui chante
l'aigle noir et celle du niagara
ça m'est arrivé que le raf à vue en
moins
bien bien des coups de poker
dernier coup de poker je serais tenté de
dire depuis le procès aussi on sait
jamais si on va gagner ou perdre
heureusement or là c'est la justice qui
a gagné donc temps et attention patrick
dupond dernier coup de rein il a ni
kudrin pas plus tard qu'avant-hier soir
ça s'est bien passé
génial